it's impossible to know how many are out
there
they can affect anyone at any age i see
people that are really really fit and
that are like operating at the highest
level of human performance and the
opposite it seems like the virus is like
picking random people to impact
all around the world there are people
suffering from long covet a syndrome
that seems to lead to long-lasting and
in some cases new or permanent health
conditions
you see a lot of horror stories out
there of people you know who are now
unemployed you know other day i got a
message from a patient she said i'm now
homeless and it's it's heartbreaking and
what is it about these random people
what do they have in common
i don't know
yeah it's still a mystery to us
everything takes way more time than it
used to
he's cutting hard
cutting's not hard
um
but it's just standing you know
the standing part is the problem
this is how difficult katie maclean's
life has become hi friends another day
in the life of long coved
today i went for my second emg testing
which is nerve testing it just felt like
i couldn't
take a full breath in
and
my head felt like i didn't have enough
air
the 43 year old is a shell of her former
self spending her days resting from her
overwhelming fatigue headaches and
general pain honestly i can't believe
this is still happening 11 months later
i can't do
anything that i want to do
anymore
mclean is a long hauler a common term
used to describe someone with long covet
when i stand up my heart rate goes
really really high so
it'll go up to like 100 and you know 120
in the first 60 seconds that i'm
standing
we first met mclean last fall at her
home in vancouver she had beaten covid
but was still experiencing symptoms so
when we sat with you a year ago you were
suffering from long covet then yeah how
are you feeling today
not better after we last talked i was
really gradually
starting to have some improvements and
then
i had a
very bad relapse in february of 2021
and that kind of brought me back to
square one
during mclean's relapse there was a
period of time when she needed a
wheelchair to get around in june she
started improving but she still relies
on a walker i was in so much pain i was
so weak i really thought like this is it
like i'm going to deteriorate until i'm
gone i'm really happy that that didn't
happen
on one of our visits mclean ventured out
the day marked her one-year follow-up
appointment at st paul's hospital post
coven 19 recovery clinic and she
couldn't miss it i'm just going to sit
down
my heart rate just goes up so high it's
like i'm running
a racing heart rate is just one of the
adverse symptoms associated with
post-covet syndrome experts say there
could be more than a hundred different
side effects the symptom profile is very
diverse and it can be anywhere from
really headache predominant brain fog
difficulties with their cognition their
memory their their thinking all the way
down to paresthesias numbness and
tingling in their toes to chest pain
dr jesse griner is the medical director
of the clinic at st paul's he's also one
of mclean's physicians
are there a lot of people
still long hauling
after a year like me there are
what do you attribute that to is it just
this virus is just so detrimental i
think the virus does something to the
inner workings of the body in a way that
we don't yet totally understand and it's
really debilitating for patients it's
it's honestly quite sad to watch in the
patients that are like not having
success in their road to recovery it's a
tremendous burden that they still bear
canada's public health agency says about
60 percent of those diagnosed with covid
reported one or more symptoms three
months after initial infection
[Music]
in atlanta 30 thrilled erica taylor has
been shut in her home alone fighting her
battle with long coven her most
debilitating symptom brain fog i have
difficulty sometimes focusing i have
difficulty sometimes coming up with a
word that i'm looking for sometimes i
fail to recognize
common objects like the time she forgot
what her car looked like one time
actually was getting into the car and
halfway with my leg halfway in it
suddenly didn't recognize my car and
thought i was getting into somebody's
else's car and
it was very scary
taylor's journey with covid started in
june 2020 the non-profit lawyer tried to
keep working but her brain was failing
her when we met her a year ago she was
forced to take a leave of absence take
out dishes from dishwasher taylor is now
back working from home despite not being
a hundred percent to help her get
through the day she has created a system
of reminders on her phone even prompting
her to brush her teeth i run a program
every saturday where volunteer attorneys
are paired up in interview
with the clients every saturday i start
off the same way i tell them that i have
neurological issues
that i'm forgetful i still have them
come back and ask me questions
like oh did you mean to send me this
no
no i didn't i'm sorry this was the one i
meant to send you
taylor's story is a scary one but part
of an emerging pattern long-haulers
often women now living with
life-altering brain fog
i want to show you what we're talking
about and while the understanding of
this syndrome is constantly evolving
some studies have shown one in three
covet sufferers may have had some type
of neurological or psychiatric issue
that means that it makes it the third
most prevalent neurologic manifestation
after tension type headache and migraine
and ahead of stroke it's what dr igor
karelnik and his team at northwestern
medicine in chicago are looking into he
oversees the nero cova 19 clinic and has
seen hundreds of patients the major
population coming to the clinic were
younger
they were previously
never hospitalized but thereafter they
developed persistent
lingering and also debilitating
neurologic symptoms including brain fog
interestingly
seventy percent of those patients were
women while the evidence to suggest that
it affects more women than men is not
concrete karelnik has a theory that long
covet is a form of autoimmune disease a
condition where the immune system
attacks its own body by mistake we know
that women are more likely than men to
develop autoimmune disease such as
multiple sclerosis and so it is possible
that there is a
predisposition for this patient to
develop the long-covet syndrome which
may in fact be a manifestation of
autoimmune diseases
at washington university in st louis dr
ziad al-ali is one of the leading
authorities on long covet as a clinical
epidemiologist he started to study the
syndrome after reading personal stories
about the plight of long haulers that
was sort of the eye opening for me that
oh you know something is happening here
and really deserves to be investigated
and really kudos to them they cut they
actually even named the disease so
al-ali and his colleagues went to work
studying the records of more than 70 000
patients who got kovid 19 and what they
found was alarming some developed
serious chronic conditions that would
probably need to be treated for the rest
of their lives when we now talk about
covet we talk about you know the toll of
hospitalization and death that is really
only the tip of the iceberg what we now
know
we know that covet 19 can cause or can
lead to
increased risk of new acid diabetes and
also new onset kidney disease and and
what we know about these diseases that
they're really chronic diseases they
don't go away
to make matters worse everyone is at
risk according to al ali regardless of
whether a person's infection is mild or
severe they are in danger of getting
long covet meaning even those who never
had symptoms could develop lifelong
problems associated with the disease why
this is important because these are the
people who represent the majority of
people who go with 19. most people with
covert 19 don't need to be hospitalized
most people go with 19 nurses at home
and then they get better but in that
group of people that is
we found that it actually remains a
significantly increased risk of
long-term manifestation
as for erica taylor she's seen many
doctors even had a brain scan but she
still doesn't have any answers i'm told
to do brain puzzles i have
so many brain puzzles now that i've
downloaded and i do those every day
it's been a long journey
definitely a very long journey and
with a whole bunch of trials and errors
in a variety
of ways
so far taylor has persevered but remains
fearful she'll never heal she's
currently on a number of post-covet
clinic waiting lists and hopes they'll
be able to help her build upon the tiny
improvements she's made over time
i go through almost
daily struggles
because i
i want to be who i was before
you know i want to
be able to react as quickly as i used to
and be as on top of things as i was
and
it does make me sad but then i just
continue to remind myself that okay this
is who i am now and i just have to work
with what i have
on a brisk day in early october of this
year ken borg heads to a hockey arena in
rural ottawa
[Music]
the 60 year old is about to play in the
opening game of the season
and he's ecstatic
i love hockey and this group of guys i
play with are ideal everybody knows each
other their names and a little bit of
chirping back on and off and everyone
plays at their own pace
borg's ability to play the sport was put
in jeopardy in march 2020. he was struck
with a mysterious illness he was pretty
sure it was coveted 19. it was probably
the sickest i felt in my life it was
very scary and why i call it one of the
worst days of my life
because i knew what it was you know it's
all i could do without panicking just to
keep breathing
very shallow breaths and uh trying not
to you know think too many bad things or
or calling 911. because it was so early
on in the pandemic borg never got tested
but he had all the symptoms
borg says he eventually got a covet 19
diagnosis from the doctor over the phone
i had heart palpitations every day brain
fog
still had problems with my lungs
covetous highest blood pressure i've
ever recorded
[Music]
every day was difficult weeks went by
and borg wasn't getting better
he had to admit to himself he was a long
hauler a condition that can affect those
who've survived covet but are still
suffering from its symptoms it varies
from person to person i just couldn't do
anything
um
that exerted my heart lifting some wood
helping people out i would have the
whole afternoon and evening with a
concussion kind of hangover feeling for
the rest of the day all i could do was
lie down
and
you know it's horrible but in may 2021
after being sick for more than a year he
got his first coven 19 vaccine shot and
says he started to feel better
i did notice after the vaccine a lot of
things improved so i was very curious
hockey
how would it be
i had this huge like dangerous heart
rates a year ago
playing hockey so i'm really hoping for
some improvement there's a small number
of patients that feel like the vaccine
has cured them of their illness although
that's not persistent in all cases
either
dr jesse griner has been treating and
studying patients at the postcovid19
recovery clinic at st paul's hospital in
vancouver
we have spoken to some patients who say
as soon as they did get the vaccine
their long coveted symptoms went away is
there some legitimacy to that yeah it's
difficult to say because we still
there's still so much that we don't
understand about how long covet works
it's possible that there's a
psychological impact what is the
potential risk of fully vaccinated
people who get the virus ending up with
long covered it's a little bit too early
to know the answer to that question
there was recently a report published
out of the uk that suggested that
patients that had breakthrough cases
that were previously vaccinated were
potentially at a 50 reduction in the
risk of developing long covert so that
has me optimistic that actually our
vaccine rollout will curb the amount of
long covet that we see in this province
at the arena borg is putting his ticker
to the test it's the first time hitting
the ice with his league since being in
recovery mode and he wants to see if his
body can handle it
to track his improvement borg is wearing
a heart monitor
it didn't take long before he had to
bench himself borg's legs were fine but
his heart was giving him trouble i did
carry the puck in you know
set something up and had a bit of fun
and when i looked at my watch it was 165
and so
165 beats per minute which is
above the danger zone for
for me being 60 years old
after almost an hour the game was
complete
made it
the league doesn't keep score but borg
tallied up his progress so i've been
checking it every shift and it's
dramatic you know it goes up to 150
when i play defense and normally i'm a
forward so i've just been taking it
really really easy and it's still
getting very high
it seems borg still has a little way to
go to get back to his pre-covet form but
he is encouraged by the fact that he is
stronger than before i'm building up
strength i'm walking farther
i was taking naps every day for the last
year and a half
i've moved off that
i'd like to know why i have this crazy
high heart rate but i'm hoping i will
see some improvements over time
i'm so exhausted today
for more than a year katie mclean has
been in and out of the hospital trying
to get answers but doctors still don't
know why she isn't getting better on
your chest
three one two three the once healthy and
avid walker has been diagnosed with
chronic fatigue syndrome and postural
orthostatic tachycardia syndrome which
affects blood flow
both conditions may have been triggered
by the virus for me to try and do a
normal activity
there's a price to pay so
my body
doesn't have the energy
to do activities of daily living
one explanation for what's causing long
covet is t cells in the body which
normally go from cell to cell to find
those infected and destroy them are
reacting differently against the
coronavirus and experts don't know why
there is a growing body of evidence
showing reduced t cell counts in
hospitalized covate patients with severe
pneumonia at this point we can say that
the response
of the t cell from the lung holders is
strikingly different from the one who
are the covid convalescent we don't have
any lingering symptoms
in the lab dr igor koralnik has been
actively pursuing this hypothesis and
the emerging picture that we get from
this study is consistent with an ongoing
persistent low-level infection with the
virus in the lung haulers which we are
currently investigating
but without any definitive answers
mclean is left to manage her symptoms
mostly on her own so this is my
supplement cupboard she takes a handful
of supplements every day and sees a
physiotherapist
it's affected every aspect of her life
what's the toll been like on your
partner
well it's been difficult because really
she had to care for me full time for
many many months and
do everything we definitely have had
some rough times but i think it's made
us stronger to just get through all this
adversity together
sorry
mclean is trying to turn adversity into
strength hoping that one day she'll be
rid of the sickness and walk away from
her life as a long hauler the doctor
believes that long haulers are going to
get better yeah do you believe that
i have to believe that because otherwise
i think
i would feel
a lot of despair and depression on top
of the other you know pain and
difficulties
that i'm dealing with so i
do
try and remain optimistic about it